former first Minister facing the music
fresh from her arrest as a police
suspect examining SMP finances it's not
an easy period but again I'm not saying
that for sympathy this is a serious
process at the center of yet another
media circus Nicola sturgeon was defiant
would it be the best thing for you to
temporarily step back as some of your
colleagues have suggested I searched my
soul in these questions what that would
do I think would be to compromise my
ability and my right to assert the
position that I hold absolutely which is
that I have done nothing wrong
it has been a painful period this is her
house in April raided by detectives as
part of this long-running probe that has
also seen her husband and the party's
former Treasurer detained and later
released without charge yet again this
is the only story in town just at the
very moment the new first Minister here
at Hollywood has been trying to move on
bogged down in discussions about his own
party under police investigation looking
on as Paul suggests the snp's popularity
is sliding the last few weeks and even
couple of months have been really
difficult for the s p possibly even some
of the most difficult months to be faced
as a party in our recent history what I
can't allow that to do what I won't
allow that to do is distract me from the
job I'm not just leading this party that
I love and I've been a member of for
almost 20 years but importantly and
crucially leading the country but the
opposition say this is a government
Paralyzed by chaos it's all away from
the business of dealing with to do the
NHS crisis cost living crisis and more
and more of this Psycho Drama that's
around it Nicola sturgeon now wants to
draw a line under this thank cute all
very much indeed but she and her party
are not in control of events as
detectives continue their inquiries
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh